today we're talking about io
returning to the office with chrome and
a few ai updates
i'm alicia and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you
the lowest latency news we've all been
working from home for a while now
and as we get back to the office chrome
os will help us make that a seamless
transition
at google we'll be moving to a hybrid
work week where most googlers spend
approximately three days in the office
and two days wherever they work best
it's no surprise but as the modern
secure cloud-first platform
chrome os is playing a key role in our
transition to a hybrid work model
because chrome os devices can easily be
shared
more flexible working models and spaces
are now possible
we're excited to announce that we've
made contact center ai
even stronger with agent assist for chat
now in public preview agent assist
provides your human agents with
continuous support during their calls
and now chats by identifying the
customer's intent
and providing them with real-time
recommendations such as articles and
faqs
as well as responses to customer
messages to more effectively resolve the
conversation
pytorch is an open source machine
learning and deep learning library
predominantly used in research and has
gained tremendous traction in the
industry as well due to its ease of use
and deployment
google cloud ai platform is a fully
managed end-to-end platform for data
science and machine learning on google
cloud
in this new series of blog posts pytorch
on google cloud
we aim to share how to build train and
deploy pi torch models
at scale and how to create reproducible
machine learning pipelines on google
cloud
io was last week and if you missed the
virtual event be sure to check out the
technical talks on your favorite product
youtube pages
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you